Could you tell me your name please?
Chen Hui. My English name is Charles.
What kind of place do you live in? A house, a flat, or a dormitory?
I live in a flat, on the top floor of a tall building.
It's in the northeast of Beijing, in a residential and commercial area.
It's quite big for just one person.
Do you like living there?
Definitely. As I said, it's quite large.
There are plenty of facilities and green areas in the neighborhood.
For example, there are three parks within walking distance of my home...
...and there's a swimming pool nearby.
It's fairly quiet, though my neighbors can be a little noisy sometimes.
What do you like about the rooms in your home?
My flat has a large living room, a kitchen, a bathroom, a hall, and two bedrooms.
I like the living room and main bedroom because they are spacious and stay bright all day.
The kitchen is not very modern and rather small, but it is good enough for me.
How long have you lived there?
I've lived there for just over a year and I hope I'll be able to stay there for a lot longer.
My landlady is helpful, dealing with any problems quickly and without any fuss.
My friends often tell me horror stories about how their landlords treat them.
What kind of house or apartment would you like to have in the future?
I'd like to have a big house on the outskirts of an historic city.
The house would have three floors and a garden where I could relax in summer.
Ideally, it would have a swimming pool!